- How has motherhood been?
- Oh it is the absolute best.
I have never experienced this
kind of love before, and-
- [Kelly] That's so awesome.
- [Kate] It's so fulfilling.
- [Kelly] Mhmm
So your husband plays baseball,
I'm not a huge sports ball fan,
I call it sports ball for a reason.
But they guys on my staff
have been fangirling over
your husband all day.
(crowd cheering)
So if you don't know, her husband
is Astros pitcher Justin Verlander,
who recently pitched his,
is it, third no hitter?
- Yeah third no hitter.
(crowd clapping)
- [Kelly] That's crazy
- Yes
- Is that like a record, like?
- Yes, I think he's
like one of three people
to ever have more than
two no hitters like ever.
- That's crazy.
- Yes
- So he's super good too, okay
- That's insane.
When, were you there when it happened?
- I wasn't, I was actually
on vacation you know,
we gotta get away.
(laughs)
- You were like, "hope you're having fun,
"but I'm at the beach so."
- Yeah exactly, I was like that's so cool.
- Yeah okay, sports ball, you get me.
- Yeah
- Okay okay.
But you're married to an
athlete, are y'all competitive?
- Oh we're super competitive,
we actually can't be on
separate teams on any-
- You'll get in a fight?
- We'll get in a huge, we'll
probably get divorced so yeah.
(laughing)
It's like we only pinpoint on each other
and we're like all right,
it's on, you and me,
and that's it, no one else
is there in any group games.
- Okay Kate, we have to have
a game night at some point,
cause I'm a die hard gamer.